on me
turn yeah Brown the back
foot
it's turn you're gonna turn turn No
one two one two
don't have their senator driving travel
clock with you you're gonna pretty
straight on this need to captivity don't
ask a lot of that need you split the
split over there you're gonna lose your
balance and you're gonna strain the knee
one here's your deviation boom deviate
clear the top
they tried let go of the line the fight
is rotate you want it to rotate so
sometimes you're over here and you're
kiting over here if you're putting
tension all the right side your body cut
you I thought I'd let the fight rotate
sort just draw
daddy
so the first one is show minute okay so
what I don't want to do is shift and
move my senator are you gonna sneak
between my legs and it goes back to here
and don't really clear the line on that
long okay so as you watch there's
there's a small slow gradual deviation
to the to the line on the other one it's
going to be a more immediate shifting
it's not quite there as you see but when
I take this step it is death
so the first one deviate off not move
out then my foot does this big thing
here at the end immediately boom clearly
then the next one so what he's here my
hands if I take this way and go really
far that's an off the cut so just we're
here just enough to clear that shoulder
here come here
whoa not gonna be here right on this
hands whoa then my next move comes into
escrow
whoa so this is a drill here shift turn
the see I still got me move the foot
just enough to kill that off you know
finish cut pull on top the hands not the
wrists on top of that
sort then in boom come back pretend is
on the stroke don't put your hands here
use his resistance so come from
underneath boom
so the key sake stroke level and my
hands are gonna be about solar plexus
level shift off whoa
in all right let's try ok I'm not giving
you the technique and just showing you
the vectors in the mind ok so here's
this tough ok and what I'm saying is if
I move if I leave my senator grabber if
you took my feet you see I'm on the line
step you see that and then I'm not going
to be off the line until I swing this
way all the way around is the center
part is between my two feet now I'm off
the line now a lot of you do this and
you ignored the tension you just put off
the energy cause you're asking a lot of
your attorney so if I got rid of that
I'd be here so I'm going to do to myself
for you
here's the other thing that happens when
you do that double pivot you're actually
out of range
attach each time this is why a lot of
your Aikido is further away than it's
supposed to be ok
so not only including the line very
slowly but I move very far I straight my
leg I'm gonna bring a lot of attention
to the left side of my body and I'm
actually out range when I do the other
deviation I'm here boom I'm here there's
less strain to know stringy on my knee
and I'm in range for the house next move
when I come up don't go through the
hands to the throat
stay off the hands bring your body to
your to your Center to your hands whoo
so I'm here so I go yet
then the Yaak boom and co-op come back
don't take the check write it off right
away cuz that's gonna be there keep the
check off move to it and then pull too
late okay try to get couple ways that
you can test would you like to have kid
and young behaviors okay so when we're
here like this and he's pushing and I
move you've seen his balance go I go
like this I might feel hold him up so he
were here and I went up boom
but when I when I hit here I'm grounded
on the back foot the back foot is ground
you say he's pushy and I can't reject
off of the back foot so not like this
where I get up around my not that thing
on this corner I actually live why then
the next one when I come forward
so then younggu okay let's try here and
I move that's the deviation so we're
just doing it slow I'm gonna free this
space if you see I'm not free he's
moving me
so on the first minimum under previous
thing by rotating
[Music]
really all that then the next one is
going to happen not after I go through
and accelerate here deviate then set it
up again it's Amish it's all the weight
shift you see that would be the foot and
I can enjoy you guys see that
so one drill here lady bracing and then
shoving him here so the line okay it's
still pushing on you see that okay so
what you're doing is your center of
gravity is between your two feet that's
why I'm still pushing on you until you
move out of the way with that bathroom
it looks like it works the only problem
is when I'm here and I go quicker boom I
control where that lot of gravity is
actually going to give you the radius
distance my you need watch I'm going to
do a steady push keep it going feel the
push I mean still going it's still going
and now I'm moving his liner graphic
because I'm still
go I'm still moving it you see you see
now okay just say you can see what's
happening you're in between your feet
you feel the pressure
yeah I guess no pressure still pressure
then please move in my line of gravity
put on there like this but I go there
all you see you see so I'm free my lion
gravity which means you can't do Kazushi
on I'm freezing the position this is a
night little attack not an angle
deviation so for example this happen
comes forward boom here if you're
pushing on my line they actually never
hits you you run into it here boom do
you guys see this difference here we go
so shift and now start to turn on that
don't lean backwards turn that's it
then step step that's it again charge we
get it off turn two bring this foot in
with you turn that's it step but you're
twisting yourself up okay bring your
foot we go here okay
so he's gonna read even do showing up
with this hand
whoa finish your cut laughs then he's
gonna hold that end of my sword and
that's going to be my projection point
so I'm gonna move to it and I'll be able
to project him a cookie projection so
here goes his weapon huh
get a little closer okay then we're
going to learn to see yes boom come back
here then next row here move to it
boom
Oh move to it and oh okay that's project
he rises up wool comes down make sure
you got it
again we're gonna do another single flip
it point turn comes up right now -
straight ski
don't start turning ski then get gone
needy the toes single pivot point foot
comes in that's all we're doing right
now single pivot point angle the top et
me poom shifts straight single pivot
point turn yes no yarn
yeah
okay just that without the story go
so I'll define it one more time
double pivoting this is my center of
gravity my line of gravity is between my
two feet no single pivot center gravity
is on the back foot passing this what
can move double pivot can't move I have
to fall into place
single single pivot in ski make sure
you're not turning here you're here
you're doing a form instead of
cultivating your body ski is here then
again on the single foot and again that
foot can move so young needs to toast
rotate single into the turn who can move
boom boom pop in here don't be twisted
bring this foot with your hips straight
hips again
you owe me okay let's go forget pencil
just the foot maneuvers
with the rookie straight teen you can
project routine
don't cross up with then this is the
grinding foot not Footloose okay when
you go when you go into this maneuver
here again not so far
you're not twisted up and discuss down
awkward here I'm here you cut who just
walk straight keep this side relax
no straight straight down your model
freed yourself off the XY start the
slide rotating one to keep straight here
no okay let's go alright sword
kicks up here try to leave that tip
there no leave the tip where it is and
move yourself 100 underneath that 10 so
I'm here we'll try to leave it there
boom boom boom
whoo-hoo
then you repeat say chef boom boom boom
pop okay